Перший скандал в лавах "Альтернативи для Німеччини"
стався в перший же день після парламентських виборів
Праві популісти вперше потрапили до парламенту
з часів Другої світової війни
та стали третьою силою в Бундестазі
Утім, співголова партії Фрауке Петрі
відмовилася входити до складу фракції власної партії
Вона буде незалежною депутаткою
бо перемогла в одномандатному окрузі
В період з 2013 по 2015-й роки
АдН мала чітке прагнення якомога швидше
опинитися при владі
Це і досі моє прагнення
Така анархічна партія, якою ми бачили AдН в останні тижні
може бути успішною опозиційною силою
але не може надати виборцям реалістичних пропозицій
які б дозволили перейняти урядування
І з цієї причини, пані та панове
а також через мої прагнення займатися справжньою політикою
у дусі здорового консерватизму
та бути частиною процесу
після довгих роздумів я вирішила не посідати місце
у фракції АдН в німецькому Бундестазі
Фрауке Петрі демонстративно пішла
з прес-конференції керівництва АдН
присвяченої підсумкам парламентських виборів
Партію вважають розділеною на помірковане та ультраправе крило
І останнім часом Петрі  не раз критикувала
своїх ультраправих однопартійців
які, наприклад, заявили, що слід пишатися "подвигами німецьких солдатів"
під час Першої та Другої світових воєн
і що "не варто вважати Гітлера абсолютним злом"
Попри те, що на виборах до Бундестагу АдН посіла третє місце
розкол в керівництві партії може бути ознакою
її внутрішньої слабкостi
Адже "Альтернатива для Німеччини" - одна з наймолодших
партій на цих виборах
Її створили чотири роки тому євроскептики
на знак протесту проти багатомільярдної допомоги для порятунку грецької економіки
Згодом партія перейшла на націоналістичну та антиісламську риторику
що додало їй популярності на тлі кризи біженців
Утім, коли пік кризи минув
стали падати й рейтинги АдН
Ця партія вимагає закрити зовнішні кордони ЄС
припинити потік мігрантів у ФРН
а також відкидає іслам як елемент німецького суспільства
Щодо кризи в Україні, то "Альтернатива для Німеччини"
єдина з великих німецьких партій
яка виступає за негайне і безумовне скасування санкцій проти Кремля
а також - за розширення економічної співпраці з Росією
Україна в партійній програмі АдН взагалі не згадується